This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。百分之二。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。欢迎收听我的播客《百分之二》。我将在节目中剖析在我们这个光怪陆离的现代社会中，如何展现坚韧的意志、保持体能以及建立心理韧性。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你终将破茧成蝶，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台上收听《百分之二》（2%）。欢迎收听《The Look Back At It》播客。来自1979年的那首歌，对我来说是个意义重大的时刻。84年对我也很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J，我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着去理解我们是如何挺过来的。和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的嘉宾以及我们喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听“look back at it”。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你喜爱的治疗师兼主播Keer Games主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间聚焦黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他任何地方都实在不安全去进行的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个懂行的专业执照心理咨询师交流。有多少男人穿着一套坚不可摧的铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这个能力，就非得这么做。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听并学习“Learn the Hard Way”。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生育了双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大群网络侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·兰吉尼。我简直惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transatlose. of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we as always break down the psychology of our 20s. Today we're going to have a bit more of a chit chat. Chill, sit down and discuss episode, more of a casual episode, more of a personal episode today.
在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》，在这个播客里，我们探讨20多岁时的一些重大生活变化和过渡，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客，新听友们，老听友们，无论你们身在世界的哪个角落。非常高兴你能来到这里，收听又一期节目，我们将一如既往地剖析20多岁的心理学。今天我们要聊得更轻松一些、更悠闲一些，坐下来讨论一期节目，今天这期节目会更随意一点，更个人化一点。
I like to do these every now and again. This podcast is kind of also a bit of a diary and a journal for me through my 20s, as much as I love the research and I love thinking about all the science. I also like to be able to look back on the episodes that I've done in the past and kind of see where I was at in that moment. And this episode is one of those. It's kind of a nice time, I think, to do a little check-in. The reason being is because I'm...
我喜欢每隔一段时间就做一次这样的节目。对我的20多岁来说，这个播客其实也带有一点日记和日志的性质。尽管我很热爱做研究，也喜欢思考所有的科学原理，但我也喜欢回顾自己过去做过的节目，看看自己在那个时刻处于怎样的状态。这期节目就是其中之一。我想，现在是个做个小结的好时机。原因在于……
I just turned 24. I am sure there are a lot of people listening to this who are like, oh my gosh, you are such a baby. 24 years old. What are you talking about? That is so young. But in my eyes, obviously it's the oldest I've ever been, duh. But it's also really interesting because I view birthdays with such fear and such, just such anxiety. And I think that that is a very common experience, this fear.
我刚满24岁。我敢肯定，听节目的很多人都会觉得：“天哪，你还是个小宝宝呢。才24岁。你在说什么呢？太年轻了。”但在我眼里，这显然是我有生以来最大的年纪了，废话。但这其实也挺有意思的，因为我对生日充满了恐惧和焦虑。而且我认为这种对变老的恐惧、对……
of getting older, this fear of having additional responsibilities, of realizing that time is finite and that you're kind of churning through the amount of years that you might have available on this earth. I know it sounds very extensional because it is. And I remember being maybe like 16. I have this very distinct memory of being around that age and thinking, oh my gosh, 24, that is so old. that is so old people at that age must have everything together like i'm going to have a house at that age i'm going to have children i'm going to have my little pet dog or whatever it was and here i am at that age now looking back at the vision that my younger self had and i'm just in a completely different place than i thought i would be and i don't know if it's just me but i always find that birthdays are such a point of
这种恐惧是一种非常普遍的体验。对承担额外责任的恐惧，对意识到时间是有限的、你正在消耗你在地球上可能剩下的岁月的恐惧。我知道这听起来很存在主义，因为它的确如此。我记得我大概16岁的时候，我有过一个非常清晰的记忆，那就是大约在那个年纪时我想：“天哪，24岁，太老了。真的太老了。那个年纪的人一定把一切都安排妥当了，比如到那个年纪我要有栋房子，我要有孩子，我要有我的小宠物狗，诸如此类的。”而现在我到了这个年纪，回过头来看看年轻时的自己所设想的愿景，我发现自己正处于一个完全不同的地方。我不知道是不是只有我这样，但我总是觉得生日是一个……
like reflection, but also anxiety, because it really puts into perspective, really how finite, how much finite time we actually have on the earth and how much there is to do, how much there is to achieve, how much love there is to give, and the ways in which we might be wasting that time or not taking complete advantage of that. So, yes, that is a long ramble, but it was my birthday. It was amazing. I had a great time. My boyfriend took me out for dinner and then I went out to dinner with a bunch of my friends. And it's really nice to be around friends who have known you for a while and also new friends, you know, people that I've known since high school and since literally my first day of uni. And then people I only met last year and my partner and it's just a very
既是反思的节点，也是焦虑的来源，因为它确实让我们看清了我们在地球上实际拥有的时间究竟有多么有限，还有多少事情要做，有多少目标要达成，有多少爱要付出，以及我们可能在哪些方面浪费了这些时间，或者没有完全充分利用它们。所以，好吧，这是一段冗长的胡思乱想，但我的生日过得很棒。我玩得很开心。我男朋友带我出去吃晚饭，然后我和一群朋友一起出去吃晚饭。能够和那些认识你一段时间的朋友，以及新朋友——你知道的，有我从高中起就认识的人，还有字面意义上从我大学第一天就认识的人，以及我去年才认识的人还有我的伴侣——呆在一起，这种感觉真的很好，而且这是一种非常……
beautiful experience. I always try to make a big deal out of my birthday. If you, know me personally, you're probably laughing at that statement, because you know how true that is. For my 21st birthday, I think I tried to distract myself from my fear of aging by just going all out. I had, it was literally the festival of Gemma. I had three birthday parties. It was a bit overkill. But I think in my mind, I was like, if I can make this exciting, maybe I can suppress some of the anxiety I have around my finite existence on this planet. And around, around. the fact that I am getting older and I may not have achieved everything that I wanted to at this age. It's also inevitable that on every birthday I have, I always end up crying. This year I am proud
美好的体验。我总是试图把我的生日搞得很隆重。如果你私下认识我，你可能正在嘲笑这句话，因为你知道这是多么真实。在我21岁生日时，我想我试图通过大肆庆祝来转移自己对变老的恐惧。我当时……那简直就是杰玛的狂欢节。我办了三个生日派对。确实有点太夸张了。但我想在我的心里，我当时的想法是：如果我能把这天搞得激动人心一点，也许我就可以压抑一些我对自己在星球上有限存在的焦虑，以及对……
to say I cried from a happy place, from a positive place. I felt so loved, so surrounded by good people. I think this is also one of the first times in my life that I've just felt true peace, peace with who I am, peace with where I'm at, peace with the people around me. Once again, birthdays are such a point of reflection and I think back to where I was last year and the year before when I first moved to Sydney and I didn't have any friends and the year before that when I was celebrating my first birthday after being through like a horrific breakup and not having this person that I'd been around for two years and every point every year is just kind of a further opportunity to really see how far I've come but then also
对我在变老、可能没有在此时此地达成所有我想实现的目标这个事实的焦虑。还有一个不可避免的情况是，每当我过生日，我总是以哭泣告终。今年我很自豪地宣布，我是因为幸福而哭，是因为积极的心感而哭。我感到自己被深深地爱着，被美好的人们包围着。我想这也是我生命中头几次感到真正的平静，对我是谁感到平静，对我的现状感到平静，对周围的人感到平静。再次说明，生日是一个很好的反思节点，我会回想去年这个时候我在哪里，以及前年我刚搬到悉尼、一个朋友都没有的时候我在哪里，还有再前一年，我经历了一场可怕的分手、身边没有了那个陪伴了我两年的前任，在庆祝我的第一个生日时的情景。每一个节点，每一年，都只是进一步审视自己到底走了多远的机会，但同时……
how much is left in the future. So let's talk about this fear of aging. If you can relate, I'm sure there are many of you. Why does it feel so oppressive and scary sometimes to acknowledge that we're getting older? For me, I think it's that birthdays symbolize being closer to death. And it is very innate and natural as a human, as a mammal, as a species, to fear death, to fear. what that brings the unknown. Of course, there are many people who have different conceptions and different ideas of what comes afterwards. For me, I don't think I really have one. And so thinking about how each year represents less time to be alive, it also represents less time before the unknown. And that's seriously what I'm probably most scared of.
也是在审视未来还剩下多少。所以，让我们来聊聊这种对变老的恐惧。如果你能感同身受，我确信你们当中有很多人都有同感。为什么承认我们正在变老有时会让人觉得如此压抑和可怕？对我来说，我认为这是因为生日象征着离死亡更近了一步。作为人类、作为哺乳动物、作为一个物种，恐惧死亡、恐惧死亡带来的未知，是非常本能和自然的。当然，很多人对死后会发生什么有不同的观念和想法。对我来说，我其实并没有什么具体的想法。所以一想到每过去一年就代表着活着的剩余时间变少了，这也代表着距离未知更近了。而这真的是我最害怕的。
It's not that I'm scared of the added responsibility. I think it's not that I'm scared of growing up in the sense of giving up the younger versions of myself. There's a whole syndrome around that called Peter Pan syndrome, which basically talks about people who are like fight against growing older because they're scared of what it means to be an adult. Specifically, they're scared of losing joy and wonder and a lack of responsibility and a lack of accountability. That's a whole different episode, a whole different conversation. I don't think I necessarily have that.
我并不是害怕增加的责任。我想，我不是害怕那种长大的感觉，不是害怕抛弃年轻时的自己。围绕这一点有一个完整的综合症，叫做“彼得潘综合症”，它基本上是指那些抗拒变老的人，因为他们害怕成年意味着什么。具体来说，他们害怕失去快乐、惊奇感，害怕失去不用承担责任和问责的状态。那是完全不同的一期节目，完全不同的对话。我想我并不一定有那种倾向。
I think I recognize how much of a privilege it is to get. older and what a privilege it is to age. And I've always said that I think about all my friends who are in their 30s and they genuinely just get, their lives just seem to get better. They get hotter. They get more successful. They have more money. They have more fun. They have more freedom, it seems to me. They really know themselves more. So I'm excited for that. I'm excited for my 30s. I'm excited for my 40s and my 50s. My mom seems like she's having an amazing time. Those new chapters are thrilling to me, and I think that there used to be such a sense of, like, your 20s are the best years of your life.
我觉得我认识到变老是一种多么大的特权，老去是一种多么大的特权。我一直都这么说，我想起我所有三十多岁的朋，他们的生活真的越来越好。他们变得更有魅力了。他们变得更成功了。他们有更多的钱。他们有更多的乐趣。在他们身上似乎有更多的自由。他们真的更了解自己了。所以我对未来感到兴奋。我为我的三十多岁感到兴奋。我为我的四十多岁和五十多岁感到兴奋。我妈妈看起来就过得非常开心。那些新的篇章对我来说是惊险刺激的，而且我觉得过去有一种观念，比如你的二十岁是你一生中最美好的时光。
When those are done, what you, everything else is a wasteland, like there's nothing left afterwards. That is a massive misconception. Obviously, I talk about our 20s twice a week all the time, everywhere I go, but I really don't think that your life ends the moment you turn 30. There is a recognition that there is a lot of beauty and grace and excitement in aging, but it's that catch-22 of realizing that the more you grow into yourself, the more versions you have to say goodbye to, and the less time you have in front of you. I think it's that mortality alarm, that inbuilt mortality alarm that we all have, that we have as mammals, as a species
当这些过去之后，你所经历的一切……其他一切都是一片废墟，仿佛后面什么都不剩了。这是一个巨大的误解。显然，我无时无刻不在一周两次地谈论我们的二十岁，无论我走到哪里，但我真的不认为你的生活在你三十岁生日那天就结束了。人们开始认识到，变老其实有着许多美丽、优雅和激动人心的时刻，但这是一个两难的困境：你越是成长为真正的自己，你就越得跟更多的过往版本告别，而你面前剩下的时间也就越少。我想正是那种对死亡的警觉——我们所有人、作为哺乳动物、作为这个物种所生来俱有的对死亡的警觉……
that realizes how fragile life is, that starts to really sound off and blare every, birthday because it's a significant kind of triggering event or like anniversary of acknowledgement of birth and death and how they're very like interlinked. I know that sounds very deeply philosophical, but I have honestly thought about this so much. I also think that another factor around this like fear of aging thing is that birthdays make us very conscious of time passing. When I was a kid, even a teenager, that used to really, really scare me because it felt like something I could not control, time, this like weird entity that none of us can really visualize. It was just slipping away from me and I wasn't able to do anything about it. And I would sit and I would spiral and I
它意识到生命是多么脆弱，每到生日时就开始真正地拉响警报并大声鸣叫，因为它是一个意义重大的触发事件，或者说是对生与死以及它们如何紧密相连的一种周年纪念。我知道这听说起来非常深刻且富有哲学意味，但我老实说真的想过很多次。我还认为，围绕着这种对变老的恐惧的另一个因素是，生日让我们对时间的流逝变得极其敏感。当我还是个孩子，甚至是青少年的时候，这真的、真的很吓唬我，因为它感觉像是我无法控制的事情——时间，这个我们谁也无法真正具象化的奇怪实体。它就在我指缝间溜走，而我却无能为力。我会坐着，然后陷入情绪的螺旋，我会……
would think about it and I would, I remember distinctly watching this bird at my window when I was in university fluttering. And every time it flooded from one side to the other, I was like, that's a second gone, that's another second gone, that's a second gone. Like, time is just rolling on and on and on and it feels like this freight train that's just going to destroy everything in its path and eventually it's going to destroy me. There's a lot of fear there. There's a lot of fear there, I think, from when I was a child and not feeling in control that still feels really relevant now.
去思考它，我清晰地记得上大学时，我看着窗户上的一只鸟在扑腾。每当它从这一边拍打翅膀飞到另一边，我就想：“那一秒没了，又一秒没了，又一秒没了。”时间就这样不断地、不断地向前滚动，它感觉就像是一列要摧毁它道路上的一切、并最终将摧毁我的货运列车。这里面有很多恐惧。我想，从我小时候起那种无法掌控的感觉中残留到现在的恐惧，到现在依然觉得非常切实。
And it is very claustrophobic in a sense to not feel like there is this big thing in your life. that dictates so much about your future, so much about what you can achieve, that you have no control over. Time is just existing and you just operate within it. If you get to kind of matter about it, it does get genuinely quite scary. It's also this sense of like every year I feel further and further detached from the memories and the periods in my life that I really cherish, specifically that feeling of being a child. And, Also the feeling of being a teenager and in my early 20s when I felt so chaotic and unbridled and free and just how absolutely like amazing that was, even if at the time it probably didn't feel that great.
从某种意义上说，这确实非常幽闭恐惧，因为你感觉生活中没有一件宏大的事情——它左右着你未来的如此之多，决定着你能取得的成就的如此之多——是你能够掌控的。时间就那样存在着，而你只是在其中运作。如果你开始认真思考这件事，它确实会变得相当吓人。这也是一种感觉，即每年我都觉得自己与那些我真正珍视的记忆和生命时期的距离越来越远，特别是那种身为孩童的感觉。还有……
It's this idea of like the rose-tinted lenses, right? Like we tend to look back at our memories more fondly than they actually were in the moment because I know as a child I really wanted to get older, I couldn't wait to have responsibility. and freedom, I know that I was going through a lot of hard things. I was being bullied. I know that when I was in my late teens, early 20s, I was heartbroken and unsure of who I was. But there is something about that time that I miss, that I really miss. And it is really overwhelming to realize that you're probably, you're not probably,
作为青少年以及二十出头时那种混乱、无拘无束、自由自在的感觉，以及那是多么绝对美妙的体验，哪怕当时可能并没有觉得那么好。这是一种“玫瑰色滤镜”的想法，对吧？就像我们倾向于把回忆看得比它们在当时实际经历时更美好一样，因为我知道作为一个孩子，我真的很想快点长大，我迫不及待地想要承担责任和自由。我知道我当时正在经历很多艰难的事情。我曾遭受霸凌。我知道当我十几岁快结束、二十岁刚出头的时候，我曾心碎过，对我是谁感到迷茫。但那个时期总有一些东西是我怀念的，我是真的很怀念。而且当你意识到你可能——不是可能，
you're never going to get that back. You're never going to be a kid. again. That time is past. That chapter is closed and it brings on a massive nostalgia wave for me around this time. I don't know if you guys can relate. Every time, like I know that we've said birthdays are a time of reflection. That's pretty obvious. But it's also a really deep time of nostalgia for me, thinking about all the things that I did as a child and how joyous and free I was and whether I've given those things up the older I get, whether this younger version of me would be happy with where I am.
你是永远也回不去了——这种感觉真的令人不知所措。你再也不是个小孩了。那个时代已经过去了。那一章已经合上，在这个时候，这会带给我一波巨大的怀旧浪潮。我不知道你们能否感同身受。每一次，就像我知道我们说过生日是反思的时刻。这很明显。但对我来说，这也是一段非常深沉的怀旧时光，我想起我小时候做过的所有事情，以及我是多么快乐和自由，以及随着年纪越来越大，我是否已经放弃了那些东西，现在的我是否会让年幼的我感到满意。
If it's not obvious, I'm very much stuck in, like, the romantic parts of the past rather than the reality of it. So that is, like, a massive component for me, feeling like I feel less attached to previous versions of me and recognizing that I can't go back, but then also recognizing that, like, what I'm doing right now, like, these years of my life are also going to be my golden years. and I really need to take advantage of them because in five years time, I'm going to be looking at what I'm doing right now and feeling the same way that I felt about my 20 year old self, 19 year old self, whatever she was doing. She was a mess. But she was also having a great time. And like, sometimes I think that I've kind of grown up too quickly in a sense and that I've forced myself into becoming like a real adult too soon. And I think that's because for many years,
如果现在还不明显的话，我其实非常沉湎于过去的浪漫部分，而不是它的现实。所以对我来说，这是一个巨大的组成部分，我觉得自己与过去的自己的联系在减少，并意识到我无法回头；但与此同时我也认识到，我现在正在做的事情——我生命中的这些年也将成为我的黄金岁月，我真的需要好好利用它们，因为在五年后，我会回看我现在所做的事情，并产生和我看待20岁、19岁时的自己时一模一样的感觉——无论当时那个女孩子在做什么。她当时是一团糟。但她也玩得很开心。而且有时候我觉得自己从某种意义上说成长得太快了，我强迫自己过早地变成了一个真正的大人。我想这是因为很多年里……
years of my life. It was always like how I'm very mature for my age and people being like, oh, you're very wise, wise beyond your years. And I take that as like a massive compliment. Like I really appreciate when people say that, but I'm like, yeah, but some of my friends are still doing things that just seem so fun. Like they're still learning those lessons through mistakes that I feel like I haven't gotten to make or they're still going out and partying and just like getting obliterated. And like I'm not really down for that anymore. more. But when I turn 35, am I going to be like, geez, it's been 10 years since I last, like, went clubbing. Like, gosh, I'm such a granny. And I'm, like, not even halfway through
在我生命中的很多年里，别人总是在说我思想如何比同龄人更成熟，大家会说：“哦，你太懂事了，少年老成。”我把这当成一个巨大的恭维。当别人这么说时，我真的很感激，但我心里会想：“是啊，但我的一些朋友还在做那些看起来超级有趣的事情呢。”比如他们还在通过犯错来学习那些我觉得自己没机会去犯的错，或者他们还在出去开派对，喝得烂醉如泥。而我其实已经不再向往那种生活了。但当我35岁的时候，我会不会想：“天哪，我上一次去夜店居然已经是10年前的事了！天哪，我简直就像个老奶奶。”而且我甚至还没走完……
life yet. It's this constant, like, contemplation of, like, the what-ifs and wanting to avoid regret in every sense of the word. Regret in my friendships. Regret in my career. Regret in my life experiences. Because every year, I'm more conscious that you don't get that time back. So it feels so much more valuable to me, so much more precious. to be coveted, something to really, really ensure you take advantage of. I think we did speak about this before, but it is, I think, what drives our fear of aging is the fear of the unknown. Not just in terms of death, because fear of death, I think, is a complete different subject. I think everyone in some sense has a fear of death and what comes afterwards. But the fear of the
人生的一半呢。这是一种持续的对“如果”的沉思，并且在每一个字面意义上都想要避免遗憾。对友谊的遗憾。对职业生涯的遗憾。对人生经历的遗憾。因为每过一年，我都更加清醒地意识到，时间是无法倒流的。所以它对我来说变得更有价值、更珍贵，需要去倍加珍视，需要真正地、切实地确保你去充分利用它。我想我们之前讨论过这个，但这就是为什么我认为驱动我们对变老恐惧的是对未知的恐惧。不仅仅是因为对死亡的恐惧，因为对死亡的恐惧我认为是一个完全不同的主题。我认为每个人在某种意义上都对死亡和死后会发生什么存有恐惧。但对……
unknown more so in terms of the fear of the future. I have built my like entire career at this stage of my life off of being 20. Oh, in my 20s. Like this podcast is called the psychology of your 20s. And people always ask me, oh like, so when you turn 30, you're going to do the psychology of your 30s? And I'm like, I don't fucking know. Oh my gosh. Like I'm so, I'm just trying to get through this. Like, should I do that? Will I be like ready for something different by then? like, is it any different? Like, people always message me and are like, I'm not in my 20s anymore, but this is like still the exact same kind of stuff that I'm going through.
未知的恐惧更多是指对未来的恐惧。我在人生的这个阶段，将我的整个职业生涯都建立在“二十岁”这个基础之上。哦，在我的二十岁。就像这个播客的名字叫《20多岁的心理学》。人们总会问我：“哦，那你到了30岁，是要做《30多岁的心理学》吗？”而我的反应是：“我特么怎么知道啊。天哪。”我真是……我只是在努力熬过现在。我该那么做吗？到那时我还会为别的东西做好准备吗？这有什么不同吗？人们总是给我发信息说：“我不再处于20多岁了，但这仍然是我正在经历的完全一模一样的事情。”
But yeah, really, it puts into perspective that like I realistically only have like six more years to take advantage of these experiences before I turned 30. And is my whole life going to be like the girl who talks about her 20s even when she's not in them? I don't know whether that's what I want. But I also know that I'm just borrowing fear from the future, right? Like I always think about this when we worry about the future. We're just borrowing anxiety from that chapter in our life that we're still going to feel then.
但确实，这让我清醒地认识到，在跨入30岁之前，我实际上只有大约六年的时间来好好利用这些经历。难道我的一生都要当那个即使不再年轻、却依然在谈论20多岁的女孩吗？我不知道这是否是我想要的。但我也知道，我只是在从未来借取恐惧，对吧？每当我们为未来担忧时，我们总是有这种想法。我们只是在从我们尚未经历的那个生命阶段提前支取焦虑，而到了那个阶段我们依然会感受到这种情绪。
You're just feeling that same pattern of fear and those same emotions twice. Like you don't need to worry as much about what's going to happen because it will just happen. Like part of anxiety is really just feeling like you can change things and feel. like you can almost anxiety is a motivated to do something about what you're scared about but the thing that I want to do something about is not something necessarily in my control right like some factors are but it's the future it's this like big cloud big storm of factors and things and events and just complete curveballs that like we can't necessarily interpret or predict so whilst I'm also facing that sense of like what does my
你只是在经历同一种恐惧模式和同一种情绪两次。你不需要对将要发生的事情过于担心，因为它自然会发生。焦虑的一部分其实只是让你觉得你可以改变事情，并且觉得……就好像焦虑是一种去对你所害怕的事情采取行动的动力，但我想对此采取行动的事情并不一定在我的控制范围之内，对吧？虽然某些因素是可以控制的，但未来是另一回事——这是一大片乌云、一大堆由各种因素、事件以及我们无法必然解读或预测的完全意料之外的转折组成的风暴。所以，当我同时面对这种感觉时——比如我的……
future hold. Like, what am I going to be doing in 10 years? What should I be doing now to prepare for that future that I want? Prepare for the life that I want. It also feels like time is equally running out to achieve some of the big things that I wanted to do by this age. I always think about the Sylvia Plath fig tree analogy. So if you've heard of it before, I'm sorry you're going to hear it again, but I think it's one of the most beautiful things anybody has ever said, so hopefully that's not too much of a disappointment. But in her very famous book, The Bell Jar, I feel like every girl in their 20s has read this book,
未来究竟会怎样？我10岁后会做些什么？我现在应该做些什么来为我想要的那个未来做准备？为我想要的生活做准备。它同时也让人觉得时间在飞逝，无法实现我在这个年纪想要完成的一些宏大目标。我总是想起西尔维娅·普拉斯的“无花果树”类比。所以如果你以前听说过，很抱歉你又要听一遍了，但我认为这是任何人说过的最美妙的事情之一，所以希望这不会太令人失望。但在她非常著名的书《钟形罩》中——我觉得每个20多岁的女孩都读过这本书，
or should read this book, she talks about this analogy or this vision of herself, sitting underneath a fig tree. And above her is this brilliant, beautiful, magnificent tree with sprawling branches and it goes on for metres and meters and at the end of every branch, every little tip, is a fig, is this big, rich fig. And the figs represent our futures. They represent the future versions of us that we could have if we choose a certain path.
或者应该读一读这本书——她谈到了这个类比，或者是她对自己的愿景：她坐在无花果树下。在她的上方是一棵绚丽、美丽、壮观的树，枝繁叶蔓，绵延数米，而在每一根树枝的末端，每一个小尖头上，都挂着一颗无花果，一颗硕大、丰满的无花果。无花果代表着我们的未来。它们代表了如果我们选择某种特定道路，可能拥有的未来版本的我们。
And so, like, in her mind, one fig is like marriage and a family and children are being a stay-at-home mother. Another figure is being a professor at a big famous university. another one is being like a nomad, a traveller, and then another one is becoming really fit in being an athlete, someone who runs triathlons. Like there are so many different futures that we can choose from. But every year, every month, every week that we don't choose one of those futures, they die out. There are some things that unfortunately, like you can't, like, you have a, it's like a prime time to do them. In a sense, I think about it.
所以，在她脑海里，一颗无花果代表着婚姻、家庭和孩子，或者是做一个全职妈妈。另一颗无花果是在一所著名的大学里担任教授。还有一颗是做一个四海为家的游民、旅行者，再有一颗是在体能上变得非常健美、成为一名运动员、一个参加铁人三项的人。我们可以从中有这么多的未来可以选择。但每过一年、每一个月、每一个星期，如果我们没有选择其中一个未来，它们就会枯萎。有些事情不幸的是，你无法……比如你有一个……这就像是做这些事情的最佳黄金时期。从某种意义上说，我经常这样想。
a lot in terms of like sport but also as we get older like having children is a big one as well it's the reality of being a woman is that there is a natural time limit to your ability to be a mom or to be a parent and she talks about how each year it feels like more and more of these figs are falling and there are less and less options available to her but she just cannot choose she cannot see from the outside of the fig which one is going to taste the best she wants to taste them all, but she can only climb one branch at a time. And I think that's really, really relevant here when we talk about our fear of growing older and our fear of time passing and our fear of birth taste more generally is that they represent to us the figs dying off.
我在很多方面都会想到它，比如体育运动，但随着我们变老，生孩子也是个大问题。作为一个女人的现实是，你能够成为母亲或父母的能力有一个自然的生理时限。她谈到，随着每年过去，感觉这些无花果掉落得越来越快，留给她的选择也越来越少，但她就是无法做出选择。她无法从无花果的外表看出哪一个会尝起来最甜美。她想把它们全都尝一遍，但她一次只能爬上一根树枝。我想，当我们谈论对变老的恐惧、对时间流逝的恐惧以及更广泛地对生日的恐惧时，这个比喻真的非常、非常切贴，因为它们向我们展示了无花果的凋零。
They represent to us certain doors that we feel are closing with age. Now, I have this battle in my brain because I don't necessarily think that that's true. Obviously for some things it is. I'm sorry, you're not going to be like an Olympic gymnast if you start at 30. I'm sorry, sorry to say that. Hopefully you already knew that. But in some senses, like, it is true, but for very minor, minor choices. Most things, I don't think, have an age limit on them. Most things are available. You have so much capacity for change, so much capacity and agency. to get to a point where you're like, I actually don't like how this looks. I don't like how my life feels, how I feel in it and in the timelines and the stories and the
它们向我们展示了某些我们觉得随着年龄增长而正在关闭的大门。现在，我在自己的脑海里做着这种思想斗争，因为我不一定认为这是真的。很显然，对于某些事情来说确实如此。很抱歉，如果你从30岁才开始练，你是成不了奥运体操运动员的。很抱歉，不得不这么说。希望你本来就知道这一点。但在某种意义上，这确实是真的，不过那是针对非常微小、微不足道的选择而言的。大多数事情，我认为并没有年龄限制。大多数事情都是可行的。你有着巨大的改变潜能，有着如此巨大的潜能和自主权去达到这样一个地步，让你能够说：“我实际上并不喜欢这个样子。我不喜欢我生活的感觉，我不喜欢我在其中的感觉，以及那些定义我生活的时光、故事、情节和关系，我要改变。”这正是随着我们年龄增长、变得越来越墨守成规时容易忽视的一点。我们对自己创造的现实变得越来越习惯，以至于我们忘记了，如果我们不快乐，我们其实是可以采取行动去改变它的。但我们却固守着那种“被困在自己创造的生活中”的荒谬感。这就是为什么每年我们都会感到更加恐惧。而且随着时间的流逝，每年你都会想：“天哪，有太多事情要做，因为我已经让自己在……”
plot and the relationships that define my life, I'm going to change. That is something that I think we lose sight of the older we get because we get more stuck in our ways. We get more comfortable with the reality that we've created that we forget that if we are unhappy, we can actually do something about it. But we maintain that irrational sense of like feeling stuck in the lives we've created for ourselves. That is why each year we just feel more scared. And each year, as the time passes, you're like, oh my God, like there's so much to do because I've let myself feel uncomfortable in
生活中感到不舒服太久了。我不知道。也许这只是我个人的体验。也许你听着这些会想：“她在说什么啊？这完全说不通。”完全理解，没关系。这没伤害到我的感情。这只是我胡思乱想、自言自语罢了。但我觉得真正发挥作用的最后一个因素，特别是当我们从更加心理和社会学的角度来谈论这一点时，是我们的社会不喜欢老人。它就是不喜欢。它不喜欢衰老的迹象。它不喜欢变老、成为老人的概念。如果你仔细想想，我们被灌输了无数种观念，认为年轻和青春是通往幸福和成功的秘诀。自我满24岁起，我收到的广告数量之多——
my life for too long. I don't know. Maybe that is just an experience for me. Maybe you listening to that and you're like, what is she talking about? That makes absolutely no sense. Totally get it. That's fine. It doesn't have my feelings. It's just me rambling on about what I'm thinking about. But the final factor that I think really comes into play, especially when we talk about this from a more like psychological and social point of view, is that our society doesn't like old people. It just doesn't. It doesn't like signs of aging. It doesn't like the idea of getting old, of being elderly. If you think about it, there are so many ways in which we are taught that to be young and youthful is like the secret ingredient to being happy and being successful. The amount of
我甚至还没那么老呢，但我一满24岁，肉毒杆菌的广告到处都是。绝对不行。至少对我不行。这就好像这些应用程序知道这是一个转折点，人们开始思考自己老了以后会是什么样子，并想要阻止那些我们觉得缺乏吸引力和不具美感的衰老迹象，而实际上，能够变老是一种巨大的特权和美好的事情。很多人根本没有……
ads I started getting when I turned 24, like I'm not even that old, but when I turn 24, Botox ads everywhere. Like, absolutely not. Not for me at least. Like, it was almost like these apps knew that this was like a turning point where people start thinking about how they're going to look when they're older and wanting to prevent some of the signs of aging that we find unattractive and unappealing when really it's such a privilege and a beautiful thing to be able to grow older. So many people don't get
那个机会。但我们的社会确实没有一种尊重社会中老年成员的积极文化。有太多的陈词滥调了，你知道的，比如老年人很孤独，老年人很悲伤，老年人正在失去所有的认知能力，他们的身体健康在衰退，他们的心理健康、情感健康和认知能力都在走下坡路。这就好像你在50多岁时达到了这样一个节点，然后过了这个节点，你突然就变成了一个老人，社会不再关心你了。不像关心年轻人那样关心你，于是你对未来的自己、对年老的自己产生了一种与生俱来的偏见，因为你意识到……
that opportunity. But we really don't have such a positive culture around respecting the elder members of our society. There's so many tropes about, you know, older people being lonely, and older people being sad, and older people losing all their cognitive debility and their physical health is declining, and their mental health and their emotional health and their cognitive capacities are all going downhill. It's like you reach this point in your 50s and then after that point you're suddenly an old person and society doesn't care about you anymore. Not as much as it cares about young people and so you have this like innate sense of prejudice towards a future version of yourself, towards the elderly version of yourself because you realize
我们社会中那些年龄达到这个水平以及更老的人是如何被对待的。这里面存在着如此之多的污名。与此同时，伴随着这一切的还有这样一种恐惧：衰老在我的健康方面会带来什么？这是我一直在思考的一个问题。我前几天在Instagram上发了一篇关于我在Netflix上看过的一部纪录片的帖子。改变人生，太棒了，绝了。它叫《你在吃什么：双胞胎实验》。
how people in our society who are that age and who are older are treated. there is just so much stigma around it. And then alongside that, there's this fear of like, what does old age bring in terms of my health? That's something that I've been thinking about a lot. I posted on Instagram the other day about this documentary I watched on Netflix. Life-changing, amazing, wonderful. It was called You Are What You Are What You Eat, a twin experiment.
我喜欢任何双胞胎实验类的东西，因为它们在实验上如此严谨，在科学上也如此严谨。抛开这些不谈，这部纪录片基本上探讨了不同的饮食如何影响人们的健康结果，比如他们的……叫什么来着，比如他们的生物年龄和心血管健康，有这么多的不同方面。我之所以对它如此着迷，是因为我想，当我二十出头和十多岁快结束的时候，当我上大学，然后刚搬到悉尼的那头几年里，我真的把自己的身体当成垃圾一样对待。我在饮食意义上也是如此。我并不是一直在吃垃圾食品，但我肯定没有考虑过我需要多少睡眠。我没有考虑过……
I love anything that's a twin experiment because it's so, like, experimentally rigorous and like scientifically rigorous. Besides the point, this documentary basically looked at how different diets affect people's health outcomes, things like their, what's it called, like their biological age and cardiovascular health, so many different things. And the reason I was so fascinated by it is because I think when I was in my early 20s and late teens, when I was at uni and then the first few years I lived in Sydney as well, I really treated my body like absolute crap. I was, I'm also in like a dietary sense. Like I wasn't eating junk food all the time, but I certainly wasn't thinking about how much sleep I needed. I wasn't thinking
我应该摄入多少钙质。（心想）跑完10公里后拉伸一下大概是个好主意，这样你就不会像我们这样年轻时在二十多岁时那样受到长期的肌肉损伤，我们可以如此幸运地认为健康是理所当然的。而我开始意识到的一点是：好吧，是的，我会变老，时间并不是承诺给你的，人们确实会因为没有照顾好自己的健康而死于各种疾病。在这部纪录片中，他们谈了很多关于……比如基于植物的饮食……哦，为什么这个词这么拗口？基于植物的饮食对你真的好太多了。当时我就想：“好吧，我现在24岁了。”
about how much calcium I should be consuming. That's probably good to stretch after going for a 10k run so you don't get like long-term muscle damage like we are so blessed in our 20s and when we're young to just like take our health for granted and it's something that I'm starting to realize is like okay yeah I am going to get older and time isn't promised and people do die from things in which they haven't taken care of their health and in this documentary they talk about a lot about how like a plant based by plant based oh why is that such a tongue twister a plant based diet it is so much better for you. And I was like, okay, I'm 24 now.
我最好还是变成素食主义者吧。我必须得这么做。我得开始吃维生素和矿物质了。我必须（你知道的）真正开始照顾好自己，这样我才能确保自己尽可能长时间地活下去。而真正触发我产生这种想法的其实是，在今年夏天——如果你在北半球的话，就是冬天——我和我父母、我姐姐们还有我男朋友一起去日本旅行时……
I better become a vegetarian. Like, I've got to do it. I've got to start taking my vitamins and my minerals. I've got to start, you know, really taking care of myself so that I can ensure I'm here for as long as possible. And something that really triggered it was actually going away with my parents and my sisters and my boyfriend to Japan over the summer slash winter if you're up north.
去北方，对，去北方，当时我只是觉得：“我真的很爱这些人，我想尽可能长时间地陪在他们身边，我不希望发生什么意外。”我不想到了某一个时刻，我才意识到我本可以改变我的身体老去的方式，我本可以改变我的成长方式，从而能给我更多和他们在一起的时间，有更多年去成为某个人的姐姐，成为某个人的母亲，成为某个人的妻子，成为某个人的朋友。再次说明，这是一种非常存在主义的、黑暗的理解：这个星球上的时间、活着的时间并不是有求必应的，它是有限的，在某些阶段你必须为之奋斗。随着你年纪越来越大，健康并发症将会出现，这……
up north, yeah, up north, was that I was just like, I really love these people and I want to be around them for as long as possible and I don't want something to happen. I don't want to reach a point where I realized that I could have changed how my body aged and I could have changed how my grew up so that it gave me more time with them and more years to be someone's sister, to be someone's mother, to be someone's wife, to be someone's friend. Once again, it's this very existential, dark understanding that like time on this planet, time alive is not promised, is finite, and you kind of have to fight for it at some stage. Like as you get older, health complications are going to come up and that's,
对我来说真的很可怕，作为一个一直以来——首先，一直都有健康焦虑的人。如果你听过我们的健康焦虑那一集，我想我担心这个你不会感到惊讶，但我一直都有健康焦虑，而且实际上一直处于相对健康的状况中，我曾把这一切视作理所当然。嗯，所以今年我真的有种感觉：“哦，是时候认真对待这件事了。是时候真正认真对待我的生活了。”我不知道。我希望外面的某个人能够对这种感觉感同身受：变老的感觉，以及对你无法控制时间而感到沮丧的感觉。害怕那些你可能会错过的东西，害怕那些你可能会忘记的东西……
really scary to me as someone who has always, firstly, always had health anxiety. If you've listened to our health anxiety episode, I don't think it's going to come as a surprise that I'm worrying about this, but always had healthy anxiety and always actually been in relatively good health, like I've taken it for granted. Um, and so it's just like this year I've really been like, oh, it's time to take that seriously. It's time to really take my life seriously. I don't know. I'm hoping that like someone out there can relate to this sense of like getting older and getting frustrated by the fact that you don't have control over time. Scared of the things that you might be missing, scared of the things that you might be forgetting
去完成的事情，你放弃的机会，你为了过上另一种生活而对某些生活说“不”。这些想法一直在我的脑海里盘旋。是的，我一直在提醒自己，24岁真的没有那么老。而且我很幸运，因为我有很多年纪比我大的朋友。很多三十多岁甚至四十多岁的朋友，比如我最好的朋友之一。埃里卡已经三十多岁了，我和她相处得非常融洽，我喜欢她那种生活方式。就像人们关于“二十岁是你一生中最美好的时光”的所有那些神话……
to do, the opportunities that you're giving up, the lives that you said no to to live a different one. It's just like very much on my mind. And yeah, I keep reminding myself that 24 really isn't that old. And I'm very lucky because I have a lot of friends who are older. A lot of friends who are like in their 30s, even in their 40s, like one of my best friends. Erica is in her 30s and I get along with her so well and I love the kind of life that she leads. Like all those myths that people have around like your 20s being the best years of your life.
还有像“你需要在二十岁去旅行。你需要在二十岁尝试尽可能多的不同职业。不要在二十岁安定下来”这类的话。她把所有这些都做得完全相反，而且看起来酷毙了！她过得太开心了，她做了那些她知道能让自己快乐的事情，哪怕这些事情在当下有点艰难。我想正是那些让你不再害怕变老的人的榜例，在那些你因自己正在变老而感到瘫痪、且对此无能为力的时刻，才真正具有帮助。
And like you need to go traveling in your 20s. You need to like try as many different careers in your 20s. Like don't settle down in your 20s. she has just like done everything to the opposite of that and it looks freaking amazing like she's having so much fun and she has just like done the things that she knows are going to make her happy even if they're a little bit hard in the moment and i think it's those examples of people who make you not scared to be their age that are really like helpful in those times when you're like paralyzed by the fact that you are getting older and there is nothing that you can do about
所以希望如果你正在听这期节目，你或多或少能产生共鸣。我要说的是——我想通过这样一句话来结束这期节目和这些胡思乱想：23岁是我生命中最美好的年份之一。我为24岁感到无比兴奋。我为25岁感到兴奋。我对剩下的20多岁以及其中包含的不同篇章充满期待。但老实说，我对你们——这个播客的听众——感激不尽，过去一年是如此惊艳。这里有太多的里程碑，太多的庆祝，这个大家庭有太多的新成员，还有如此多的爱。我只是……有时候你在……当我制作这个播客时，我独自呆在一个房间里自言自语。我甚至忘了此时此刻有其他人在听，在世界的另一端，那些我不认识但却一直在聆听的人。
it. So hopefully if you're listening to this, you have like somewhat related. I will say and I want to end this episode and this ramble really by just saying 23 was one of the best years of my life. And I'm so excited for 24. I'm excited for 25. I'm excited for the rest of my 20s and the different chapters contained in them. But honestly, I cannot think you guys enough, the listeners of this podcast from how amazing the last year was. There was just so many milestones, so many things to celebrate, so many new members of this community, and so much just love. I just, and sometimes when you, when I'm making this podcast, I'm alone in a room talking to myself. And I forget that there are other people listening to this right now, like on the other side, who I don't know, but who listen to
所以希望如果你在听这个的话，你们多少也有些感同身受。我想说，我想以这句话来结束这期节目和这番唠叨：23年是我生命中最棒的年份之一。我非常期待24年。我期待25年。我期待我二十多岁剩下的时光以及其中包含的不同篇章。但老实说，对于这个播客的听众们，对于过去一年是如此奇妙，我真的感激不尽。这里有太多的里程碑，太多的事情值得庆祝，这个大家庭有太多的新成员，还有那么多的爱。我只是，有时候当你在，当我在录制这个播客时，我一个人在房间里自言自语。而我却忘了此时此刻还有其他人在听，就像在另一端，我不认识但却在倾听的人
my voice and who really learn something from me or take something from these episodes. And it's so nice to hear that from you guys. And it really assures me that I'm doing something that has purpose and that is useful and that helps people. And I don't know if even if everything else in my 20s goes to shit, at least I can say that like I have the opportunity to do this. So I know this conversation has been quite pessimistic. I want to end from a place of gratitude and from a place of just like absolute acknowledgement of how privileged and happy and lucky and amazing my life is. And a lot of that is thanks to the support for this show. I'm so glad that I'm one year further in my 20s.
我的声音以及谁真正从我这里学到了什么，或者从这些节目中收获了什么。听到你们这样说我真的很高兴。这确实向我保证，我正在做一件有目的、有用且能帮助别人的事情。我不知道，即使我20多岁的其他一切都变得一团糟，至少我可以说明我有机会做到这一点。所以我知道这次对话相当悲观。我想从感恩的角度结束，从绝对承认我的生活是多么特权、幸福、幸运和精彩的角度结束。很大程度上要归功于对这个节目的支持。我很高兴我在20多岁的路上又迈进了一年。
There's, I'm sure, so many more experiences left to talk about. And I'm so excited to learn from them. I'm so excited to see what happens. If you've also had this feeling of like being scared of growing older, of aging. Shoot me a message. I would like to hear from your experience what you kind of did to counteract that or what you think some of the triggers were, like why that was the case. There's so much other research on this that I didn't get to go through. So maybe next year we'll do a replay and I'll talk to you about being 25 when I'm actually having a very serious quarter-life crisis.
我确信还有更多的人生经历可以分享。我非常期待向它们学习。我很期待看到接下来会发生什么。如果你也有这种害怕变老、害怕衰老的感觉。给我发个信息。我想听听你的经历，你是如何应对的，或者你认为诱因是什么，为什么会这样。关于这个主题还有很多我没有看完的研究。所以也许明年我们会做一个回顾，当我真正经历严重的四分之一人生危机时，我会跟你聊聊25岁的感受。
But until that time comes, I want to thank you for listening. If there's someone who you think would enjoy this episode, make sure you share it with them. Thank you for all the love and support. If you have an episode suggestion, feedback, questions, whatever it is. Feel free to message me over on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. I'm another year older. I'm feeling very lucky. Thank you for following me on this journey. We will be back next week with another episode. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
但在那一刻到来之前，我要感谢你们的收听。如果你觉得有人会喜欢这一集，请务必分享给他们。感谢你们所有的爱与支持。如果你有节目建议、反馈、问题，无论是什么。欢迎在 Instagram 上通过 @That Psychology Podcast 给发消息。我又长大了一岁。我感到非常幸运。感谢你们陪伴我踏上这段旅程。我们下周将带着另一集节目回归。2%。这是在也有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立心理韧性、健身和韧性的迹象。
Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple. podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. In 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English.
经历一些磨难，你会以一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的姿态走出困境。收听《2%》。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple 播客或你获取播客的任何地方都可以收听。在《Look Back at it》播客中。1979年，对我来说是一个重要时刻。84年对我来说很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。
Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to Look Back at it on the I Heart Radio app. Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts.
每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过难关的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是一个疯狂的年份。那是一个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple 播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor.
嘿，你们好吗？正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯主持的《Learn the Hardway》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都真的不安全的坦诚对话，但你是和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士一起进行的。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。
It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much. I doctored the test ones.
它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这个能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple 播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你伪造了这个特定的测试两次。我伪造了一次测试。
It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
这需要一大群网络侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人的经历。格雷格，一个女同性恋。迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
随着赛季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临后果。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple 播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一个 IHeart 播客。保证是人类创作。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。